for the introduction and also thanks for
inviting me here so we talk about lower
bounds on the running time for
scheduling and packing problems so this
is joint work with lin chen he was a
student for one year from china in here
two of my other students feelings in car
thailand and coach on who's the advisor
of Lin in China so under the assumption
that p is not an p equal to NP you can
see the picture like this so we have the
class of of polynomial Agrium's NP and
three subtle lies somehow in the
difference and we can only claim that
three that is not polynomials over and
what nice is by the by this workshop are
these community is to proving some
better bounds and one thing is to see
this as a landscape with different
running times of a Grimm's so 22 square
root of K where care is a parameter or
two to the 20 of k were also what we
have seen in the first talk by Vidura
and so natural parameter what we have
also seen for three third is the number
of variables or the number of clauses
and what we use mainly for the proving
the lower bounds is using the
exponential time hypothesis so that
frees our formulas with M clauses and n
variables cannot solve this time to do
data enters a polynomial and N and M and
what's also important is the
specification so that we can use instead
of n here and the number of clauses it's
important because if you want to
transform or do some reductions then it
has to relate to em and if you'd use n
then you would get worse lower bound
afterwards
and so actually at some point i read
this nice survey by Daniel marks and
some others about the ETH and
consequences and I saw there there are
many results especially for graph Eureka
problems but only few for some
scheduling or packing problems there was
one for instance for scheduling with
precedence constraints there was one by
for two dimensional vector knapsack and
with Daniel marks are also proved some
results for unary bin packing but
looking at this I thought it's a good
moment point to start work more on this
so with Lin Chen and cuddy and Felix we
started to do this wrote a proposal to
the DFG and the stories could start and
we got more and more resides in this
direction and we'll show you some of
them so we worked mainly on exact and
approximation algorithms and to see if
you can get lower bounds for both so
Andy so the main goal was for me to find
bounds for scheduling and packing
problems especially proof proving lower
bounds based on the ETH and also
sometimes to find egg rooms with some
upper bounds and the best case clearly
to find matching lower and upper bounds
some cases possible I was surprised that
in several cases really you can very
close to the upper bounds so that my
feeling was there so the ETH should be
very useful and I believe in it
otherwise I could not get such results
so I start with exact algorithms and
show you one example what most of you
probably know and I show you that subset
sum partition and other problems cannot
be solved in this time to do little o of
N and they are also some matching upper
bounds for this what we have seen also
in
talk before in the morning most of the
Agrium's be our base also for the
scheduling problems on subsets of the
jobs so you enumerate the subset of the
jobs at the beginning at time T and then
you continue and always have to store by
some generic programming subset of sets
that you have executed already and then
you get our groups with running times to
20 of em so how you can prove this
result and I found in a book by ingo
vegan or a very nice reduction that
gives you directly the proof and
therefore I think it's good that
everybody knows about this so we have n
variables here M clauses and for each
variable you create two items so truth
and the fords variable we're here you
count at this side the variable with the
index I and then you look at all
positions and the clauses where the
variable is inside and mark this here at
the corresponding higher positions and
here you do the same for the negated
variables and in addition you have two
dummy items for each Clause so but you
can see they somehow are used to match
the boundary at the corresponding
position so let us look at an example so
here's a reduction so we have two
clauses the variables when you see here
are the corresponding indices for the
variables in both cases and for instance
X 1 is in the second Clause therefore we
have a 1 here and X 1 bar this one is in
the first Clause therefore we have a 1
at this position so it encodes directly
the corresponding containment of
variables in the corresponding clauses
and then you can see we have here the
dummy items and
what's important for the reduction is so
they are no carryovers if you take some
solutions like this because you have
only here we have only two ones and here
in the worst case we have five because
we are the three sub formula so they
cannot happen if you select anything
that you somehow get your value a larger
than T and it goes over to the x
position that does not happen here
that's important so if you look at an
specific assignment so let us choose X 1
and X 3 2 true give these through
positions and here we have the Fords 4x
tool you see our automatic the variable
setting is already done and then you
have to choose here to dummy items that
it fits directly to the other and so you
see this is the corresponding subset
some solution what you get on all of
this there's a direct correspondence
between both things what in what you see
by the reduction what was known as the
three start formal is satisfiable if the
constructed subset sum has a solution
but what's nice is here the constructed
instance has only 8 m items is linear in
the number of clauses so that means it
gives a strong linear reduction
therefore if you have an algorithm for
subset sum in this running time this
gives automatically an egg room to
decide three thought and it would as a
consequence that the ETH in sports so
it's josie very easily that let these
works and we use that also as a basic
later to prove some other results so
what interesting is also you could also
look at the size of the constructed
instance that all the numbers so we have
2 n plus 2 M plus 1 numbers here and we
have 2n n plus M
that means the total size of the
instance can be bounded by this M square
that has the consequence that you can
also prove you cannot solve the problem
into two square root of the input size
and also at the interesting they are
also some matching upper bounds where
you have fear running time to two big
off this run the size here for subset
sum and also for the knapsack problem
you can fight this so that was
surprisingly for us that it also works
so for the scheduling problem the
situation is a bit more difficult so for
two machines yet you get the same result
as before but if you have also a
machines here this is the standard
notation for scheduling on identical
machines while minimizing the max payne
you get a lower bound like this here so
m so the almost a square root of M goes
inside of the exponent here and on the
other hand by dynamic programming you
can also find an egg room that comes
close to this but you need your some log
factor inside it's not clear what the
best suicide is here
now let us switch to approximation
schemes so it worked a lot on
approximation schemes for naps Accords
or scheduling problems and I wanted to
know we are are there some lower bounds
for this for some of some problems what
was easy for others more complicated the
first thing is for the multiple knapsack
problem so you have several apps X may
be of different capacities you want to
find a subset of the items that fit into
the knapsacks by minimizing the overall
profit there is an egg rim what I
developed some time ago that has a
running time to 20 of one of epsilon x
unlock factors and you can prove on the
other hand out so there's a lower bound
so there's no egg rhythm with such a
running time we're here is little off
one of epsilon if it holds also for some
special case where you have only two
knapsacks of the same capacity and
either one of these two cases so there
is implicates the first one the all
items have the same profit so you want
only to know the number of items that
you can pack and in the other case is
maximizing the overall size of the items
so what is the main idea to prove this
so what you can consider is a restricted
version of the knapsack problem so we
have to nap text as I've shown you and
let's use a capacity it's one half of
the total size so i would like to pack
everything inside so assume here that
the size the total size is an even
number otherwise i have automatically
are no instance then i need an upper
bound so I need a very hace so that the
coding language he is polynomial in the
size of the corresponding partition
problem we have only the sizes inside
and then the profit values should be
like this every item has a profit at
least value see and it's the overall
profit of all items up is bounded by the
value C times alpha and the number of
items n either should be constant here
so let us assume that we have such a
restricted version i will show you later
how to obtain these in both cases that's
what the idea now you take an instance
of the petition problem where we know by
our previous reduction that there is no
good a grim for this and reduce it to
the restricted version of the multiple
knapsack problem where the sizes remain
the same I don't change the sizes of the
items so and the point is if their
solution for the petition problem then
automatically see there is also packing
in the two corresponding knapsacks that
you can use now suppose that you have an
approximation scheme for the multiple
apps a problem that finds in 1 plus
epsilon solution in this running time
here let's take this you set epsilon 2 1
/ 4 n what follows then the claim is
that the approximation scheme packs all
items if the partition problem has a
solution so first of all you use the
bounty of the for the profit again you
get a lower bound of the value of C and
then if you know all items are packed
the algorithm the scheme has a profit at
least 1 divided by this times the
optimal value of this is by the
definition of the scheme the optimum
value if if all items can be packed if
the prophet of all items so and then by
some calculations you can see that this
value is at least the overall profit
minus severe you see using this
inequality there but on the other hand
is a profits of the prophet of
each item is that less a pc that means
there cannot be any unpacked item
because the Prophet was already larger
because you at least touch on then here
inside and the claim follows and
automatically so now you have to use the
running time so we can decide the
weather the petition is this has a
solution by running simply the 1 plus
epsilon approximation algorithm so
what's important is by these two bounds
you can prove that the input length of
your restricted version here is also
bounded by the input size of your
partition problem to some polynomial so
we have to calculate carefully here and
use these bounds here and then if you
use this corresponding epsilon value and
insert this this running time goes over
to this running time and this is a
running time for the petition problem
where we know we don't have this only if
the ETH faults so when this gives you
automatically the result so what remains
is to construct these corresponding
restricted versions the first case is
quite easy if the profit is always one
so you take a petition instance and
simply take decisis and choose always
the Prophet equal one so when we see the
profit of our items the number of items
n the profit is at least one so you can
choose I for one and C equal one and you
are done so the bounds for see is they
hold and it's fine so this is the
simplest case the other case is a bit
more complicated you have to use a
intermediate problem a petition problem
where the sizes are not too small and
not too big so you need a where you see
here where the sizes are between C and
three seeds but you can construct this
by a reduction from the potential
problem also
that means you can also prove that
there's no algorithm that decides is
specific petition problem in this time
so this property here these inequalities
for item shows that the over-sized of
all items is bounded by 3 c n the profit
is always like the size so we get an
upper bound like here in the lower ball
automatically here now because it's
exactly the size so that means you can
choose the value I far three and you
choose the corresponding where you see
what you get there and you see also the
value C satisfies the inequality de
that's important here you have to check
that the encoding length of c is bounded
by the size or polynomial of this it is
enough then you have a restricted
version here of the corresponding depth
I problem and the same thing as what
I've shown you before burbs okay look
let's also add the two dimensional
vector packing problem I've shown you
there was a result by Hadas and cooley
and could improve this further so here
was a square root of one of epsilon you
get this run low about nor unless the
ETH fades in the other reside there was
a weaker assumption enough by Hadas but
what nice is there is also an upper
bound for this by catawba and others
they proved such a running time so for
the two-dimensional case that matched
what we don't know is what happens in
the higher dimensional case the higher
dimensional case there is a egg riddim
where the dimension goes here in the
exponent but we were not able to prove a
lower bound here where D goes inside so
there may be there is a better lower
bound or a better a grin so that's one
interesting thing one can work on so the
last thing is we worked out so on the
scheduling problem on identical machines
in the sort of paper with Lin and go
chang we proved the lower bound like
this here for any data you get such as a
lower bound that means that comes very
close to little o of 1 over epsilon and
there is an upper bound so what I prove
some years ago so identical and uniform
machines where we have is one over
epsilon square inside so that means you
have also hear something there is a
little gap but fortunately recently we
were able to improve this so you get
here one of Epsilon so we are writing
this up now this together with another
student and yours a fair shake from
Santiago so we buy some clever
techniques about the configuration IRP
we could reduce the running time here
but we had also some results if you
specify the number of machines so if M
is part of is constant in this case or
as a parameter you get a lower bound
wear em goes here in the exponent you
can tell that means you can hear claim
that is specific there is no specific F
Peters for the problem on the other hand
there is also an FPT us even for a more
general problem with unrelated machines
that is harder to solve where you get
these running times and here you see
that comes also very close to this under
this specific case yes epsilon should be
smaller than one of em then you get this
so this i did with in form of each
student monogamous Fellaini from lugano
he has been maybe a nice story about
this so we worked on this is not not
publish this resides so because people
thought maybe it's not interesting
enough but maybe it's now is more
interesting because we have this lower
bound to see that this is matching
okay as a summary so if you are
interested you can look at the papers
one is that what's in the other is it's
what that soda open problems are what I
think is interesting the D dimensional
vector on except problem or closing the
gap the main complicated things are the
lock factors inside but they are not so
easy to solve there are some underlying
problems that are quite hard for
instance if you would like to improve
this year for the might have a website
problem you have some out to work on bin
packing problem instances and if you can
show for instance that they've modified
roundup property how it's so it means
the optimum number of bins what you need
is bounded by the AP value rounded up
plus one so then you can improve the
running time for the measurement website
problem another thing what's inside here
in the scheduling part is the user IRP
so a result by lens star or an
improvement by Canon where you have a
running time d 20 of D where D is the
number of integral variables so there's
hope that you can improve this to 20 of
D and then automatically would also
improve this recycler know if it holds
also for the identical automatically and
for the uniform case you would need also
reside about mixed integer linear
programs so the for uniform case is a
bit more complicated well that's it
thanks
plus I have a question to feel is the
famous problem that's in the Gary and
Johnson list in the map yeah no problem
k processor scheduling unit task length
precedence constraints different and I
think the current state is that it's
known to be polynomial for one of two
machines and there was a claim for many
years that it was polynomial for three
that nobody ever saw proof Hans and I
won't matter i had a pay for a long time
ago we purported to show that it was
hard for w 1 by a reduction from clean i
suppose somebody recently wrote and said
that our proof was flawed I'm not quite
sure with the current state but couldn't
you using a ETH conceivably show like a
lower bound of know into the K minus
Delta even though you don't know that
the problem is actually in XP correctly
maybe you can prove but there's a recent
paper by a hot faucet was on active he
proved if you use the Lhasa haveeru she
so that you get some results but you
remember this is not a polynomial I grim
what you get but it's somehow pseudo
polynomial that gives us something in
the exponent but it seems a promising
direction using mathematical programming
techniques to improve this or maybe that
is also the border now and then you can
proof or to lower bounds but i'm not
sure enough what can be done by concrete
question and what are the exact figures
for the equals 3 4 for this be done
vector texture exact numbers I think in
the exponent if I make no mistake juice
d minus one goes in the exponent square
divided by epsilon the epsilon remains
there no bond is only what we have so I
don't know what happens how the D goes
inside now that's an interesting thing
not to work on them some resides for
related problems by Nikki van zile but
maybe can be used so I'm not sure he did
some work about the vector scheduling
problem if i remember correctly
you